Billy thanks for being here I'm doing
great how are you guys let me come here
though we love Helen also booked me
thank you he's gonna close yeah yeah
yeah
blocks down we see you all the time yeah
I always see Andy coming out of the gym
and I'm smoking no I don't I don't go to
that I don't go to that gym anymore but
every time I would go I would work out
for like an hour I'd come out sweating
exhausted and you're sitting there
having a cigarette in the shade I think
it's funny to smoke and watch people
play basketball play nice speaking of
sports first season we're gonna bring it
I got to bring it up I am a from Boston
I am a Patriots fan you are of course a
Steelers yeah and our teams played each
other I don't quite remember who won
well you won we won
yeah we did win how'd that go over in
your house smells horrible it's a
horrible thing whole family suffered
because you beat us yeah because I I go
to bed and I'm throw everybody out of
the house but you know miraculously
enough when we were up there our
headsets a boss a rock station came into
our headsets but now I just don't know
how that happened okay yeah right every
time somebody plays you yeah yeah I'm
not buying that one I am there are other
scandals that have happened with the
Patriots so I think okay what's going on
here but that one with the headsets 3011
well we're gonna feel if you think it
caught a shark
you think Belichick intentionally put a
rock station I don't put nothing by that
organizer okay all right so Steve all
right you still got a catch boss still
gotta run still got a kick was it a song
by Boston does that really fishing
you're welcome subtlety I tell you you
lost a bet with Michael Malley
previously well they make me that made
me did this this picture up I got a lot
of Boston buddies and Mike O'Malley is a
dear friend he was on a show called yes
there was a story yes yeah and I was I
was a guest star reoccurring character
and we got to be good buddies and he's
of course a Patriots not like you and
and I'm a Steelers fan so there was the
AFC Championship this is back before I
know they were no they were video
recording our team anyway my little
Astra okay but anyway a little
bitterness doesn't play well and just go
ahead tiny big Conan be honest anyways
but we made a bet and I said okay if I
win you have to wear whatever Steeler
gear I bring in for the day for eight
hours and if you win I'll wear whatever
Boston gear or New England gear you
bring in so I'm thinking I'll bring in
like a you know like a hard hat and I
make him carry a lunch pail and a
Steelers Jersey sure a simple kind no
big deal and he can do it yeah so what
what I learned in show business that day
was don't make a bet with a guy who has
access to the Warner Brothers costume
department he dressed me like one of
those old pages I look like Captain
Crunch for eight hours did you bring
[Applause]
yeah that's my archenemy Ben yeah he's
in our fantasy football league he's
nobody's with our Mounties the bossing
Isaac wait a minute I got to get a
picture with him I got to get a picture
with him and so all day long the crew
guys you know I'd go outside for a smoke
or something the crew guys would be
driving by hey Ben Franklin how you
doing hi
but I owned up to the bet I paid up did
you go to his Steelers games as a kid
was that a fun experience I did but we
sat way like I think my kid did the
games now to sporting events and it's
you know different because we're on TV
and we can afford good tickets right now
if I can't suck them out of Warner
Brothers once in a while right but I
yeah my dad would take us and we'd sit
up in peanut heaven you know people go
why is it called peanut heavens because
the players look like peanuts right so
far up there so you guys your dad didn't
have a lot of money to spend
how's it different I I kind of want to
take my kid to some crap seats so he
knows the difference yeah because like
in those days like my dad was like don't
even look at the souvenirs if you look
at the souvenirs I'll hit you don't even
order food in the stadium you like he
would get a hoagie which is a submarine
center back east and he'd whack it into
fours and he'd wrap him in foil and then
he'd go here put that in your pocket you
eat that in the third quarter take my
kid and I'm trying to make up for some
scar and my childhood yeah and I think
my son is a Dodgers fan and I walk him
through the statement it's like there's
a force of gravity pulling the souvenirs
behind him by the time he gets to the
seat he looks like a vendor bad I'm a
sad wasn't that a great clip subscribe
to my youtube channel for an endless
supply of me
[Laughter]